it's such an exciting time in my life
yolanda hadid
is a proud grandma she couldn't help but
share the most
precious photo of gigi holding her baby
girl
in the instagram pic the 25 year old
model snuggles up to her little one
and is seen kissing her on the cheek
yolanda added a sticker that reads
you are my sunshine it's a beautiful
time in our life
the former real housewives of beverly
hills star has been loving her new role
as grandma
just last month yolanda gushed over the
family's new addition
by posting this sweet photo writing my
heart is expending with so much love and
joy for this little baby girl
she is an angel sent to us from above
thank you mommy and daddy for making me
aoma
i love every minute of it she's sunshine
gigi and her boyfriend zane malik
welcomed their first child together in
september
the supermodel has been sharing little
updates on instagram about mom life
just last week gigi shared a photo of
herself looking like a natural
writing a whole new kind of busy and
tired
and for thanksgiving she was cozying up
to her daughter
it's amazing to have my family in
october a source told et that gigi and
zayn had their first
date night thanks to grandma i'm the
anchor i'm the matriarch
of my of our family obviously and
energetically i'm always there
i'm the person that they turn to the
couple enjoyed some quality time
together as yolanda watched
their little one gigi and zayn have
completely thrown themselves into being
hands-on parents and they love it
every day is an adventure the source
adds that they are more in love now than
ever before
i feel so grateful the new parents were
first spotted together in 2015.
things got hot when gigi starred in
zayn's music video for his single pillow
talk the following year
i think that he is so talented and
you know comes from such a genuine place
of loving music
et spoke with gigi back in 2016 where
she said zayn wowed her from day one
did he wow you on date number one of
course i mean
i i i met him in person um
once before he's obviously so gorgeous
but
really the way that we could have
conversations and kind of just
were really interested in the same
things and it was really easy